during one of Trump's speeches in Iowa
over the weekend
a voter confronts Trump about the
vaccines the very vaccines which Trump
takes credit for and takes a pride in as
one of his biggest accomplishments
during the covid Pandemic those vaccines
that his supporters mostly are against
and won't receive
a voter says we lost a lot of people
because you supported the Jab
and this gets super interesting take a
look at this
yeah
well you know everybody wanted a vaccine
at that time and I was able to do
something that nobody else could have
done getting it done very very rapidly
but I never was a mandates I was I
thought the mandates were terrible
and and
you know there's a big portion of the
country that thinks that was a great
thing you understand that not a lot of
the people in this room but there's a
big but there is a big portion
some people think the vaccine was a good
thing you know I would have loved to
have seen Trump say when she says we've
lost a lot of people because you
supported the jab Trump goes yeah
I would have preferred Trump to say
what do you mean we've lost a lot of
people because I supported the job what
exactly are you talking about Force the
voter to say well hundreds of thousands
millions have died from the covet
vaccine now I think it's important given
the opportunity to remind everybody
there is still no credible evidence
about covid vaccine related deaths there
was a misleading report put out by a
group called The Institute for pure and
applied knowledge they used completely
bogus methods and assumptions to
estimate probably 300 000 people died
from the vaccine they used an excess
death sort of calculation what's funny
is they didn't even include the
possibility that the excess deaths were
from covid from the thing that was
actually killing people
uh there was a false claim that Pfizer
revealed data that
um death as a possible side effect was a
common thing when people were in the
test group The Trial group or whatever
um that's been completely debunked what
it relates to is that there are people
who died in the few months following
vaccination which you would expect from
groups of humans some people die for
reasons that have nothing to do with the
vaccine so the Pfizer one was a big
thing now it is true that people
occasionally die from common vaccines
they are insanely rare cases and they
usually involve a sort of known
theoretical risk of death and the real
numbers are so so so small a couple
examples anaphylaxis which is a really
severe allergic reaction after any
vaccine there can be anaphylaxis usually
happens within minutes of the vaccine
can be treated with epi nephron the rate
of anaphylaxis after vaccination is
believed to be somewhere between 1 in 10
cases per million vaccines administered
and of course the epinephrine shot will
will save most of those 1 to 10 per
million there is something called
intussusception which is a type of bowel
obstruction when you get the rotavirus
vaccine which is given to infants and
young kids really important to protect
against severe diarrheal disease there
can be a risk of intussusception after
the rotavirus vaccine one to five cases
per hundred thousand doses administered
uh GBS
Guillain-Barre syndrome very rare nerve
damage disorder can happen after the flu
shot the risk is about one to two cases
per million Doses and then you know you
can look at the yellow fever vaccine
there's something called why
e-l-a-v-d
to severe reaction to the yellow fever
vaccine and
um that is important in some parts of
the world the risk of that is under one
case per 100 000 doses administered so
can people die after a vaccine yes is it
so so so rare absolutely is there any
proof that people are dying from the
covid vaccine there is not but this is
what we call when a trump voter
confronts Trump about the vaccine he
created and wants credit for this is
losing control of the monster you
created I've mentioned it before and
we'll have the clip of this interaction
on our YouTube channel on our tick tock
on our Instagram if you or one of your
parents is starting to lose your hearing
you're not alone about 48 million
Americans have hearing loss and only one
in five people who would benefit from
using a hearing aid are actually using
one our sponsors MD hearing create FDA
registered rechargeable hearing aids
that cost a fraction of what you
typically pay for example MD hearings
new Neo model costs less than 10 percent
of what those marked up hearing aids are
being sold for at most hearing clinics
and the Neo is MD hearings smallest
hearing aid ever no one will even know
that it's there I have a close family
friend who uses MD hearing and loves it
she said it performs better than any
hearing aid that she's used and it's far
less noticeable MD hearing even offers a
45-day risk-free trial with a 100
percent money back guarantee so you can
buy with confidence and they have a
special deal for my audience when you
buy a pair of hearing aids you'll get
them for just 149.99 each plus they'll
include a free extra charging case go to
mdhearing.com and use the code Pacman
the link is down below